we are just hours now until a big CNN
debate live from the Brooklyn Navy Yard
Bernie Sanders Hillary Clinton face off
Sanders absolutely needs to win the
state of New York if he's going to have
any realistic shot at winning the
Democratic nomination but it's it
possible that Bernie's bad economic
ideas will win even if he loses think
he's going to win I honestly think he
will but if nothing else this has
inspired a political revolution that
will not go away after this primary is
over Ernie's platform has moved Hillary
very far to the left the fifteen dollar
minimum wage now she's talking debt free
education before there wasn't debt free
education I put it like this she's like
coca-cola Ernie's like the Black Label
Cola but people are starting to taste
that black Cola and they like hey it's a
lot cheaper it's a lot safer I like that
that we got to end this starvation
minimum wage of seven and water raised
at the 15 Secretary Clinton said let's
raise it to 12 there's a difference if a
Democratic Congress put a fifteen dollar
minimum wage bill on your desk would you
sign it of course I would now as a
candidate for president you say that by
the time you're done with all your rules
and regulations fracking will be
restricted in many places around the
country why have you changed your view
on fracking you know we are in vigorous
agreement here senator I think it's
important to point out that you know
we're having a discussion about the best
way to raise money from wealthy people
to extend the Social Security trust fund
the debate showed that Hillary Clinton
feels compelled to move left toward on
precisely those issues that Bernie
supporters are most excited about
economics trade tuition if you think
about the issues that Hillary doesn't
seem to want to budge an inch on it's
those ones where Bernie agrees the most
with libertarians for instance during
the debate on the drug war and this is a
difference between the secretary and
myself as I understand it we have got to
have the guts to rethink the so-called
war on drugs too many lives too many
lives have been destroyed because people
possess marijuana Hillary's response to
what to do about mass incarceration more
universal pre-k and when Sanders rightly
danger for sowing chaos in Libya she had
the temerity to suggest that what we
really needed is more intervention into
Syria nobody stood up to Assad and
removed him and we have had a far
greater disaster in Syria that we are
currently dealing with right never go
ahead unlike Ralph Nader in 2000 or
Jerry Brown in 1992 Bernie Sanders seems
to have struck a major chord with
Democratic voters particularly the young
sadly it's for his worst policies not
his best for reason TV I'm Matt Welch
yes